the Joe Rogan experience the way I look
at like seasons of racing is kind of two
key ones you have like your spring early
summer and you're kind of late summer
fall / winter season so it's kind of -
so I'll basically just sacrifice one of
those seasons for this and I probably
won't I mean I don't really know what to
expect I've never done anything quite
like this before but I'm planning on
dedicating one of those seasons towards
that exclusively Jamie's nodding over
here he's guys digging through this
article is pretty interesting so it
started here like this it's walking was
a huge spectator sport in the late 19th
century they would bet money that like
you couldn't do it people followed it
like it was the World Series so it
continued on until the Great Depression
World War two probably because people
didn't have enough time to waste their
time doing this and then it picked back
up in the late 20th century and that's
when you had to prove what you were
doing look at this the first known
transcontinental journey took place in
1896 by a mother-daughter duo who
needing to raise money to save their
farm in Spokane County Washington
responded to a ten thousand dollar
public wager that no one could make it
by foot across the country Helga and
Clara SB left home with $10 between them
as well as a compass a knife a curling
iron and a Smith and Wesson revolver
don't [ __ ] with those ladies they'll
curl your hair and shoot you in the dick
they made it to New York City seven
months later but for reasons unknown did
not receive any reward for their toils
on their way home Helga and Clara took
the train what the [ __ ] why didn't they
get paid someone [ __ ] them out of their
money probably someone [ __ ] him out of
their money some jackass yet so it
started again picked up back up again in
like the 60s and in 1980 somebody's
somebody I was doing it had his team
scramble to get witness signatures the
whole way across so he could prove that
he did it right yeah yeah I mean people
cheat on marathons right there yeah
jumping cars and marathons and making on
the train there was a guy I think before
Pete broke the record that I think got
caught cheating track okay you got a
document stuff pretty detailed and you
know it's crazy like I mean you'd think
you
would be enough just to track it on your
watch and upload it right but like you
know people do goofy things like they
get in the back of the RV I guess and
drive really slow but who are really
good at like looking at those GPX files
can look and see like oh that's not a
run that's you know they can see these
variances and paces or consistencies
that wouldn't be uniform with running or
something like that
well maybe there should be some sort of
a video recording of it like your GoPro
in your head I want to do a live feed
just have it possible satellite yeah
it's just really a way to do it yeah
that would be dope listen man we're in
will help you whatever we could do this
sounds sounds like a very worthy cause
and it's a crazy undertaking and we'd be
happy to promote it too and let
everybody know and have people [ __ ]
honk their horn and drive by oh we're
going Dairy Queen
[Applause]